[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans ce
nouveau numéro du 78 politique 1 78
politique en direct du Parlement
européen de Bruxelles comme tout les
mois nous interrogeons un eurodéputé
d'Île-de-France pour connaître notamment
son point de vue sur l'actualité
européenne ce soir Guillaume Balas
eurodéputé socialiste francilien et
notre invité nous évoquerons avec lui la
montée inexorable des parti extrémiste
sur le Vieux Continent nous parlerons
également des travailleurs détachés un
sujet brûlant pour l'Europe depuis
maintenant de nombreuses années cette
émission permettra aussi de découvrir
l'une des mères fondatrices du projet
européen Simon veille en collaboration
avec l'association jean-monet basée dans
les Yvelines l'Europe à la carte vous
sera également expliqué en collaboration
cette fois-ci avec la Maison de l'Europe
des Yvelines enfin les yvlinois auront
la parole puisque élus du territoire et
habitants interrogeront notre invité sur
la question de leur choix Guillaume
Balas bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes
eurodéputé socialiste depuis 2014 avant
cela vous aviez siégé au conseil
régional d'Île-deFrance vous étiez
d'ailleurs entre 2010 et 2014 le
président du groupe PS à la région
pourquoi vous avez décidé de d'embrasser
une carrière européenne en 2014
qu'est-ce qui vous a poussé à vous
engager pour l'Europe carrière
européenne c'est pas le cas puisque
c'est un mandat électoral ce n'est pas
un métier mais j'ai eu cette réflexion
en effet il y avait cette possibilité de
devenir députés européens en même temps
ce que je faisais à la région me
passionnait ce qui m'a peut-être le plus
décidé c'est quand beaucoup de mes amis
m'ont dit tu passes ton temps à
critiquer l'Europe tu passes ton temps à
dire que ça va pas alors je suis
profondément pro-européen tu as
l'occasion de mettre les mains dans le
camboui tu peux pas non plus voilà être
contradictoire sur le sujet faut y aller
donc c'est un sujet qui vous tenait à
cœur de depuis longtemps qui vous
investissez depuis que je suis rentré en
politique je pense que c'est un des
sujets majeurs l'Europe en tout cas
s'est construite en grande partie grâce
au Père fondateurs de l'aprèsguerre
parmi ces pères fondateurs il y avait
aussi des femmes comme Simon ve en
France Jean-Philippe Louen le président
de l'association évelinoise jean-monet
nous présente le parcours de cette femme
qui a marqué son époque et qui a été
élue le 17 juillet 1979 président du
Parlement
[Musique]
européen voici le résultat du scrutin
madame ve
voix c'est particulièrement symbolique
que pour pour les premières
élections au suffrage universel ce soit
une femme et en plus une femme avec un
tel parcours qui se soit retrouvé
Présidente je pense en effet que nous
partageons la même volonté de réaliser
une communauté fondé sur un patrimoine
commun et un respect partagé des valeurs
humaines fondamentales de par son
parcours évidemment une femme qui a été
elle-même déportée pendant la Seconde
Guerre mondiale qui a été à l'origine
aussi des lois euh pour le le
libéraliser l'avortement donc dans son
pays euh donc elle ne pouvait
qu'apporter des valeurs euh en plus du
du du du projet à l'époque de de qui
était plus finalement un grand marché
commun au niveau de de la Communauté
européenne et euh les citoyens ne
voyaient pas très bien ce que quel rôle
jouait ce ce Parlement européen qui
était à l'époque d'ailleurs avant elle
composé de de membres des par Parlement
nationaux qui ét désignés envoyés au
Parlement européen le fait qu'il y ait
des grands leaders politiques a permis
sans doute de mobiliser les électeurs de
les intéresser à ces élections et
maintenant je crois que ce seront les
travaux de notre Parlement leur qualité
qui devra suffisamment motiver les
électeurs et pour que la prochaine fois
nous ayons des élus qui vraiment soient
ensuite décidés à se consacrer
complètement à leur tâche par de
parlementaire européen donc elle a elle
a véritablement mis le Parlement
européen sur la sur une nouvelle voie et
je dirais elle a vraiment voulu que le
Parlement européen soit beaucoup plus
connu par exemple elle a fait elle a
acheté la maison jeanmonnaie à cette
époque hein puisque c'est sous sa sa
présidence que cette modeste demeure où
l'Europe est né euh a été acheté par le
Parlement européen pour qu'elle reste un
lieu de mémoire de tous les Européens
elle était très sensible à cette idée
d'avoir une une mémoire commune et des
lieux qui symbolisent la paix elle qui
avait connu la guerre l ce qu'il a de
plus terrible la déportation dans les
camp de
concentration l'Europe se doit d'offrir
à tous ses citoyens le plus de liberté
possible dans un souci de coexistence
solidaire et pacifiier en multipliant
les échanges dans tous les
[Musique]
domaines Guillaume Balas l'histoire le
parcours de ces hommes de ces femmes qui
ont marqué l'Europe est-ce que c'est
important de se les remémorer parfois de
s'en rappeler aussi de de leur idée à
eux de la conception qu'ils avaient de
l'Europe surtout en C temps un peu un
peu trouble pour le Vieux Continent oui
et non oui parce que évidemment
l'intuition que l'Europe doit s'unir
pour être plus forte dans le monde et
que surtout c'est un facteur de paix
c'est un élément absolument crucial et
on le voit aujourd'hui dans les temps
troublés dans lesquel nous nous rentrons
non dans le fait que il faut passer à
une nouvelle étape et que on ne peut pas
construire l'Europe qui vient euh
uniquement sur les intuitions des années
50 euh je crois que c'est complètement
dépassé et que il faut aujourd'hui
affirmer des orientations complètement
nouvelles notamment dans le domaine
économique dans et dans le domaine
social on le voit ces paires fondateurs
ont très peu réfléchi en fait à la
question de comment aujourd'hui l'Europe
ne devient pas une jungle pour ses
propres habitants euh notamment par une
concurrence déloyale il imaginez
peut-être pas une Europe aussi aussi
large aussi donc ça ne correspond plus à
l'époque et donc s'il faut garder les
intuitions he s'il faut garder la flamme
il faut pas en garder la cendre et donc
il faut faire quelque chose de
radicalement nouveau parlons du présent
désormais l'actualité européenne marqué
par deux faits marquants la victoire
d'un candidat écologiste lors des
élections présidentielle lors de
l'élection présidentielle en Autriche et
contre un candidat d'extrême droite et
la démission de mattho Renzi en Italie
après la victoire du nom au référendum
sur la réforme des institutions quelle
est l'actualité la plus marquante selon
vous celle qui vous a le plus marqué je
pense que d'un pur point de vue européen
il est évident que la démission de
mattho renzy est un élément important
pourquoi parce que Matthéo Renzi avec
qui je peux avoir des tas de désaccords
par ailleurs sur nombre de sujets est
sur le plan européen un de ceux qui a le
plus porté l'idée d'une réorientation de
l'Europe et d'une Europe qui fasse plus
en terme d'investissement en terme
social alors certains disent il a
instrumentalisé ce discours il n'a pas
fait grand-chose derrière mais il faut
voir qu'il n'avait pas beaucoup d'alliés
non plus y compris la France d'ailleurs
pour pouvoir appuyer ce ce projet donc
on va voir ce qui va se passer je ne
suis pas sûr que Matthéo Renzi ne soit
pas le futur Premier ministre en Italie
il y aura un nouveau gouvernement à un
moment il y aura de nouvelles élections
on verra bien ce qui se passe en tout
cas il est évident que sa démission
aujourd'hui marque un tournant
euh en même temps faut faire attention
il n'est pas vrai de dire que les
électeurs italiens ont voté contre
l'Europe à travers ce référendum je ne
sais pas d'où est né cette idée il n'y
avait aucun rapport entre la question
européenne et la question qui était posé
celui qui portait le le poids du nom
c'était BP griot
anti-européen reconnu alors d'abord le
mouvement 5 étoiles est très compliqué
parce que est-ce qu'il est vraiment
totalement anti-européen oui il est sur
sur la question de l'euro par
ex exactement mais c'est plus compliqué
que ça quand on voit notamment les gens
du mouvement 5 étoiles ici mais c'est
pas pour ça que renzy a perdu renzy il a
perdu parce que d'abord sa réforme
constitutionnelle allit sans doute un
peu trop loin par rapport à ce que sont
les équilibres trop vite trop loin par
rapport à ce que sont les équilibres en
Italie et surtout parce qu'il a été
l'auteur d'une loi qui ressemble à notre
loi travail en France qui a beaucoup
précarisé notamment les jeunes et que
les jeunes sont venus en masse voter
contre lui puisque il avait mis sa
personne en jeu mattho Ren qui a étaé
une très grande erreur évidemment dans
ce référendum donc je crois que c'est
des ressorts très italiens qui en fait
amènent à la défaite du de la position
du Premier ministre et sa démission en
Italie ça a quasiment rien à voir avec
l'urope vous soullignez la réforme du
Code du travail vous voyez un parallèle
entre le destin de mattho Renzi et celui
de François Hollande alors c'est voilà
il y en a un qui démissionne parce que
il a perdu au référendum un qui annonce
qu'il ne se représente plus vous vous
voyez un parallèle en plus c'est deux
sont de gauche il il il est certain que
l'orientation j'ais dire de d'une gauche
vers le libéralisme d'une gauche
libérale est en train de mourir
aujourd'hui voilà c'est clair c'est en
train de mourir on voit bien que ça perd
partout et que si si les
socio-démocrates les socialistes au
niveau européen ne se recentrent pas
aujourd'hui à gauche pour y compris
proposer de nouvelles protections face à
la mondialisation elle a un grand risque
de mourir c'est clair quoi qu'il arrive
ces deux actualités et notamment la
victoire d'un candidat écologiste en
Autriche marque un nouveau tournant pour
l'Europe et pour une nouvelle victoire
en quelque sorte pour les partis
europhobes puisque le FPO a quand même
réussi à à recueillir près de 47 % des
voix en Autriche on a l'impression avec
le brexit avec toutes les nouvelles qui
qui nous arrivent comme ça que que c'est
un on est dans un cercle vicieux pour
l'Europe qui ne se sortira jamais de ce
cercle vicieux est-ce que vous avez
cette impression là aussi et notamment à
très court terme est-ce qu'on peut en
sortir avec les élections allemandes et
les élections françaises qui arrivent
alors c'est en lien en fait avec ce
qu'on disait précédemment je crois pas
que ça soit que l'Europe je pense que
c'est tout le monde occidental
aujourd'hui qui est pris de convulsion
pourquoi parce que depuis la fin des
années 70 il y a eu une grande vague
néolibérale la mondialisation libérale
et la gauche a fait une grande erreur la
gauche modérée c'est que au lieu de
contester frontalement cette
mondialisation libérale elle a dit on va
jouer le jeu de cette mondialisation
libérale mais on va la réguler et on va
réussir à faire en sorte qu'elle
bénéficie à tous Le Paris a échoué la
mondialisation libérale a eu lieu mais
elle n'a pas profité à tous et les
inégalités ont explosé les gens se
sentent aujourd'hui fragilisé or
l'Europe était une promesse de
protection par rapport notamment aux
gens on disait l'Europe ça va être un
contrepoid face à la mondialisation or
elle en a été un agent actif de cette
mondialisation donc c'est pour ça que le
problème qui se pose aujourd'hui c'est
que les partis qui disent revenons à
avant la mondialisation c'està-dire les
partis nationalistes et europhobes
revenons au trente glorieus revenons au
Front national revenons à des États
providence qui se limitent à à nos états
et surtout où il n'y a pas de
d'immigration ça beaucoup de succès donc
la question qui
POS justement parce que je crois que le
débat aujourd'hui n'est pas encore
achevé au sein de la gauche et que la
transformation de la gauche est en train
de se faire moi j'étais notamment au
conseil du par Parti socialiste européen
à Prague ce weekend on voit une
évolution extrêmement forte c'est-à-dire
que les socialistes se rendent compte
qu'ils ne peuvent plus continuer à avoir
j'allais dire une position entre deux
chaises et que un moment il faut choisir
et donc nous devons être nous les agents
de manière modérée responsable et
intelligente d'une rerégulation de la
mondialisation et donc de la contester
dans ses fondamentaux notamment la
mondialisation financière vous êtes
Guillaume Guillaume Balas excusez-moi
pour une une Europe plus sociale
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire une Europe
plus sociale par exemple quel projet
vous vous portez vous euh on a euh
réussi à mettre en place une monnaie
unique avec des pays qui avaient des
histoires extrêmement différentes des
économies extrêmement différentes et qui
s'étaient même tapé dessus pendant
longtemps et aujourd'hui on voudrait
nous faire croire qu'il est impossible
de mettre en place des processus de
convergence sociale je ne demande pas
que demain matin il y ait les mêmes
salaires partout et les mêmes normes
sociales partout non il faut un
processus de convergence long s'il le
faut progressif mais qui amène à faire
en sorte que l'ensemble des Européens
converge vers un modèle qui est un
modèle semblable qui s'y oppose en
réalité deux forces la première c'est
évidemment les néolibéraux les forces de
l'argent qui n'y ont absolument pas
intérêt et pour qui l'Europe est
aujourd'hui un champ de dumping social
extraordinaire alors est-ce qu'on peut
Rapp ce que c'est le dumping social
parce que vous êtes auteur d'un rapport
làus c'est très simple c'est quand vous
allez jouer justement du fait que les
systèmes sociaux sont très différents et
les niveaux sociaux sont très différents
entre les état pour faire de l'argent
hein je prends un travailleur d'un pays
à très bas cût je mets dans un pay par
exemple je le mets dans un pays où les
coûts sont élevés comme ça ça va me
coûter beaucoup moins cher et je me fais
de l'argent et ces forces là aujourd'hui
poussé par le grand patronat européen
s'oppose aujourd'hui à une Europe
sociale et puis il y a les pays de l'Est
les pays de l'est pas tous les pays de
l'Est c'est les syndicats dans les pays
de l'Est sont en faveur d'une Europe
sociale ce sont eux qui profitent
généralement alors ils profitent en
effet pas beaucoup c'està qu'ils ont pas
beaucoup de choix c'est c'estàdire qu'on
a tellement enfermé les pays de l'est
aujourd'hui dans une économie de très
basse intensité avec extrêmement peu
d'investissement productif que ce qu'ils
exportent le mieux finalement c'est leur
main d'œuvre à bas cou c'est l'économie
lowcost donc je crois qu'il y a une
réflexion globale à avoir y compris avec
les pays de l'Est pour leur proposer un
nouveau Pact et ce nouveau Pact c'est
une politique d'investissement au niveau
européen y compris dans les régions qui
sont les plus défavorisé à à l'Est et en
échange progresser vers l'Europe sociale
convergence sociale vers le haut vous
parliez de de très long terme est-ce que
le but même si c'est pas pour tout de
suite c'est que tout le monde a les
mêmes salaires les mêmes normes sociales
très long terme certes mais est-ce que
je préfère dire équivalent ou semblable
je vais vous expliquer pourquoi c'est
que il y a des différences que l'on peut
tout à fait admettre je pense que par
exemple les pays du nord de l'Europe ont
un système de relation entre le patronat
et le syndicat qui fait qu'il n a très
peu de règles sociales fixées par l'État
c'est la négociation collective qu' est
fixe donc eux ils aiment pas beaucoup
les règles sociales qui sont imposées
comme ça d'en haut c'est à respecter ce
qu'il faut c'est une forme d'équivalence
entre les droits sociaux et surtout la
capacité que quand un travailleur aille
dans un autre pays et bien il n'y a pas
une distorsion de concurrence au
détriment des travailleurs du pays
d'accueil on parlait des pays de l'Est
ce que vous proposez ça va surtout
profiter aux gens des pays de l'Est en
quoi un français a beaucoup de choses à
gagner qui a déjà un niveau trè social
très élevé en France à quoi un
travailleur français par exemple a gagné
à une convergence sociale vers le haut
sur l'ensemble de l' c'est l'invers
aujourourui ça va profiter à tous parce
que le problème aujourd'hui c'est que
quand vous êtes un transporteur français
et que vous êtes concurrencé par des
entreprises des pays de l'Est qui ont
des coûts beaucoup moins élevés que vous
ou alors une entreprise de vous êtes un
petit entrepreneur dans le bâtiment et
que vous n'obtenez aucun appel d'offre
parce que vos salariés sont français
alors que les autres emploient des
travailleurs détachés je peux vous
assurer que aujourd'hui dans les deux
cas ces entrepreneurs ces chefs
d'entreprise sont très favorabl à une
Europe sociale vers le haut pour faire
en sorte que la concurrence se fasse sur
les compétences et non pas sur sur le
coût du travail vous avez l'impression
que les choses bougent en ce moment que
que votre rapport par exemple est
soutenu que que vous disent vos
collègues de il étéu puisque il a été
voté à une grande majorité ce qui
n'était pas acquis au Parlement européen
il y a donc une position politique oui
il y a une position politique du
Parlement européen aujourd'hui qui est
extrêmement claire il y a un deuxième
débat maintenant qui s'ouvre sur le fait
de redéfinir la directive détachement
des travailleurs just ou qui dat de 96
qui date de 96 pour remettre justement
des règles un peu plus claires et un peu
plus équivalentes entre les travailleurs
des pays à Bakou et des pays à haut
standard de de niveaux sociaux et c'est
maintenant qu'on va en discuter j'espère
qu'on trouvera une majorité si nous ne
trouvons pas de majorité sur ce sujet
alors j'ai bien peur que les citoyens se
détournent de l'Europe très rapidement
on va revenir à la politique française
une Europe plus sociale moins austère
c'était aussi la promesse de François
Hollande en en 2012 euh vous estimez
qu'il a totalement échoué là-dessus ou
alors vous lui donnez quelques quelques
bons pointstalement non totalement ça
serait quand même extrêmement injuste il
y a une chose que François Hollande a
fait c'est de bien ça s'appelle l'Union
bancaire en gros c'est une solidarité
entre les banques aujourd'hui et qui
fasse que c'est pas notre portefeuille
qui a la prochaine crise aille les
supporter même s'il y a encore des
lacunes pour le reste oui il y a de de
de de très grands manque et je pense que
c'est dès le début du quinquena
malheureusement quand François Hollande
refuse de renégocier les règles
budgétaires européennes ce qu'on appelle
le TSCG que il loupe le coche parce que
sans les avoir renégocié évidemment il
s'est rrouverver dans une situation où
il a fallu admettre des règles qui
étaient très néfastes pour l'économie
française et donc un certain nombre de
lois comme la loi travaill en on découlé
et malheureusement je pense qu'il s'est
trompé François Hollande qui ne se
représente pas à l'élection
présidentielle Benoît hon qui est lui
candidat à la Primare c'est le candidat
que que vous soutenez officiellement
vous croyez une vraie victoire de de de
ah oui je pense qu'il est au cœur à la
fois de ce qui est l'histoire de la
gauche et en même temps de la société
qui vient c'est-à-dire qu'il est très
attaché à la protection sociale
contrairement à Monsieur Fillon ou même
un certain nombre de socialistes qui
n'ont pas eu de problème pour par
exemple flexibiliser encore plus le
marché du travail lui il pense que les
jeunes actifs ont droit à une protection
sociale comme leurs parents ont une
droit à une protection sociale mais
qu'elle doit être totalement nouvelle
c'estàdire que il faut rénover la gauche
pour qu'elle qu'elle puisse protéger les
gens aujourd'hui quelle est la
différence ce sera ma dernière question
sur la politique française entre benoî
Amon et Arna mondbourg on a du mal
parfois il y a beaucoup de convergence
sur nombre de sujets avec peut-être deux
éléments ah B il y aura un rassemblement
au prier Tourou de tour on verra comment
le débat va se faire il y aura un
rassemblement évidemment mais la
question qui se pose c'est qu'il y a
quand même une différence assez forte
sur notamment la question écologique je
pense qu'il y a de la part de Benoît
amont une réflexion écologiste beaucoup
plus avancée que chez Arnaud mbourg on
en vient maintenant à notre rubrique et
chez nos voisins ça se passe comment la
France est l'un des pays qui compose
l'Union européenne elle appartient
également à la zone euro et l'espace
Schengen mais ce n'est pas le cas de
tous les pays comment s'y retrouver dans
une Europe à la carte les précisions
d'olivier Jean Wex responsable du Centre
d'information Europe Direct à
Saint-Germain en
[Musique]
l' pour les pays de l'Union européenne
il y a un socle commun qui s'applique et
on va dire que après par exemple la zone
euro l'Union économique et monétaire ça
c'est du bonus la zone euro c'est une
zone de 19 pays membres de l'Union
européenne qui ont une particularité
c'est d'avoir donc une monnaie unique
qui est l'euro c'est-à-dire qu'ils ont
accepté de sacrifier leur monnaie
nationale afin euh justement donc de
mettre en place cette monnaie unique
cette zone a été notamment prévue à la
base par le traité de Maastricht donc en
1992 et a été formellement et
concrètement mis en place en 99 c'est à
partir de là qu'on a eu les premiers les
premières pièces qui ont circulé il y a
des exceptions notamment pour trois pays
donc le Royaume-Uni le Danemark et la
République tchèque parce que tout
simplement ces pays ont négocié pour que
il n'est pas il ne soit pas obligé
d'avoir l'euro alors c'est un choix euh
c'est un choix strictement national mais
la règle veut tel que c'est prévu dans
les traités que tous les pays qui
entrent dans l'Union européenne à terme
et l'euro comme monnaie l'espace
Schengen concerne actuellement 26 pays
de l'Union
européenne les accords ont été signés en
85 à Schengen c'est une petite localité
au Luxembourg et ils sont entrés en
vigueur en 95 et donc concrètement c'est
la suppression des cont ô au frontièrees
donc vous n'êtes plus arrêté par des
doigners quand vous passez dans un autre
pays vous n'êtes plus arrêté pour
présenter et justifier de votre identité
donc le gros avantage que ça bah c'est
justement le fait de ne plus attendre
aux frontières on peut passer
tranquillement c'est un gain de temps
énorme notamment lorsqu'on va en
vacances on n plus obligé on n plus
arrêté on n plus arrêté pendant 3h
obligé d'attendre son tour c'est aussi
un gain de temps par exemple pour les
personnes transfrontalières qui peuvent
aller travailler beaucoup plus
facilement dans un autre pays et aussi
pour les entreprises qui exportent dans
un autre pays de l'Union européenne
parce que ce temps qui est gagné c'est
du temps de salaire en moins à payer les
inconvénients c'est que tout simplement
comme on a une libre circulation et
qu'on ne contrôle plus ben on ne
contrôle plus qui vient donc on ne peut
plus on ne peut plus faire un contrôle à
la frontière donc c'est-à-dire que s'il
y a des criminels qui décident de passer
dans un qui décid de passer d'un pays
pour venir en France c'est possible du
moins ils ne seront pas ils ne seront
pas bloqués à la frontière alors après
ça ne veut pas dire qu'il ne sont qu'on
peut pas les qu'on peut pas les arrêter
à un autre moment mais on ne pourra pas
les bloquer à la
[Musique]
frontière cette émission se veut aussi
interactive l'Europe fait souvent
l'objet de reproche trop complexe pas
assez transparente voire inutile parfois
pour certains et bien nous donnons la
parole à des acteurs de la vie locale
pour vous poser une question sur
l'Europe une question de leur choix et
c'est David ouillet député les
républicains des Yvelines qui vous pose
une question Guillaume Balas ne
pensez-vous pas pas qu'au niveau de
l'Europe il serait temps
d'arrêter la construction de norme et de
contraintte
administratives qui touche l'ensemble de
la société française est-ce que pour
vous on peut la stopper voire même
revenir en arrière pour alléger tout ça
et donner un peu plus de souveraineté à
chaque pays pour que chacun se cale par
rapport à ses caractéristiques quels que
soi les domaines est-ce que c'est
possible David dou accuse l'Europe en
gros de créer trop trop de normes de les
appliquer de la même façon pour tout le
monde qu'ors on n'a pas tous les mêmes
caractéristiques vous en pensez quoi de
cette réflexion déjà ah bah je pense que
si on devait suivre ce que dit David
Douet ça sera une catastrophe ça serait
la fameuse Europe à la carte c'est ça
bah il y aura plus d'Europe du tout et
surtout pour le coup la mondialisation
libérale ferait ses plus grands dégâts
je vais prendre un exemple aujourd'hui
faut-il plus de normes ou moins de
normes écologique au niveau européen sur
les OGM les pesticides qui sont on le
sait autorisés complètement dans
certains états moins dans d'autres sur
tout ce qui est norm de santé de
production sur les normes sociales par
exemple est-ce qu'on veut plus de règles
au niveau européen ou moins de règles au
niveau européen si on met moins de
règles au niveau européen ben c'est très
simple on va approfondir la concurrence
entre les États y compris en termes
social on va approfondir la concurrence
notamment euh pour attirer les
investissements donc on sera de moins en
moins regardant sur les critères sociaux
sur les critères écologiques bref on va
rentrer dans une compétition généralisée
pourtant les les opinions publiques ont
généralement cette impression de de
l'Europe une marchine qui fait beaucoup
de normes pas forcément compréhensible
très bureaucratique très lourde c'est
vrai qu'il en grande partie ça c'est
c'est juste je rappelle quand même que
maintenant il y a une procédure au
niveau de la Commission européenne alors
ça fait toujours technocratique de le
dire mais qui est justement d'alléger au
maximum ces normes très sincèrement je
pense que la France n'a pas besoin de
l'Europe pour mettre des normes qui sont
des normes parfois très peu utiles
notamment pour les entreprises donc
regardons-nous nous-même plutôt que
d'accuser tout le temps l'Europe sur ce
sujet une dernière question il y a une
idée qui fait beaucoup son son chemin
dans le débat politique c'est d'une
Europe un retour un OAU dur quitte à
aller plus loin peu de pays moins que 27
actuellement peu de pays mais pour aller
encore plus loin vous en pensez quoi
vous est-ce quement favorable notamment
sur un sujet qui est le sujet budgétaire
je pense que aujourd'hui l'Europe doit
investir massivement pour ça il faut
qu'il y ait un budget européen donc il
faut qu'il y ait un gouvernement
économique européen et donc il faut
qu'il y ait un parlement qui contrôle
démocratiquement ce gouvernement
économique je pense que la zone euro est
le est le bon priimètre mais ça peut
être aussi oui ça peut êt en dessous si
jamais tout le monde ne veut pas y venir
mais j'y étais très favorable il y a 6
mois très favorable il y a un an
j'aurais aimé que la France soit plus
moteur sur ce sujet merci Guillaume
Balas d'avoir participé à ce 78
politique version Europe je rappelle que
vous êtes eurodéputé socialiste d'Île de
France vous pouvez consulter l'ensemble
de nos émissions sur TVfil 78.com au
revoir merci
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]